foreign
but as we all know there's always an
even bigger dumb waiting in the wings so
you might as well give him a surname
why not a prefix as well something like
doctor Ballin also a typical nightstand
with a charging phone loose change and
Roku remote is too typical I say it's
like a crime scene that's been staged to
convey normalcy and I don't trust it
[Music]
a plot device the show wants us to focus
on so we don't notice that a couple of
seconds later he's still running up the
same stair set
[Music]
God country and Rick James by not just
saying super freak the camera's case on
Hardcore is super long because someone
was worried the perpetually naked
Peacemaker wasn't enough to Telegraph
how horny this episode is he's running
out of these stairs so long that I'm
beginning to think that these are
Penrose stairs and that Inception was
actually set in the dceu
you can't see me jerk off about that can
you thinking you have time to stop and
ask this save the wicked Wango questions
for when you're safely away from the
police Peacemaker hey hardcore you want
to see me rub one out well you can have
his ass okay I have to give a little
credit to the writers for making having
time for this 90 of peacemakers
Personality it's respectable but also
sinable Peacemaker just killed a damn
butterfly yelling critical Mission
details about the top secret creatures
you're fighting with that and all the
banging you've definitely woken up at
least half the floor if they're anything
like me they've run to the window to get
the tea God damn it cursing your father
for the free uniform he gave you instead
of all the racist he says it does
wouldn't it make more sense to just grab
your clothes and then get dressed once
you're safely away whether you're in
underwear or this uniform you're going
to attract the same amount of attention
super Seeker clandestine government spy
weapons always need to be assembled on
their way to the operation and by no
means are they to be tested to make sure
all the doohickeys are in the right
place I guess that would be bad for the
suspense and wouldn't look nearly as
badass
no laptop wakes up that fast you gotta
press all the buttons on the keyboard
for five to ten seconds put in your
password wait for steam to update and
then you can use it there's not much I'd
believe you wouldn't a bowl of oatmeal
grapefruit some yogurt grapefruit nah
despite what girlstrip says there's way
too much acid in there for me to risk it
you'd be in the emergency room faster
than you could say Peacemaker and I know
this because it happened to a friend of
mine yeah a friend do you pet the dog
when he looks cute in these clothes
questions that don't need to be asked
and shouldn't be dignified with an
answer Peacemaker finds this device
which will likely be important because
he's rummaging through a dead person's
belongings when he should be concerned
with getting the [__] out of there which
would be fine if dumb luck was listed
among the features of his shiny head
condom I don't think you have chips I'll
come right out to you why are you
feeding him chips hardcore's sudden
concern for eagle's diet is not going to
be enough to distract us from the
longest and most drawn out escape from a
condominium scene I've ever seen is that
somebody in a window up there I mean
that storm direct apartment yet you've
been on the scene for several minutes
now and that's clearly where something
important happened
why is dance was he expecting Sophie to
join in you know what reverse that the
sin is detective song not joining in
now my heart stopped beating well then
you should either go to the hospital or
stop being such a pedantic [__] at TV
since that's my job I'm pretty sure
someone on set must have said maybe
we're spending too much time on the
stairs then James Gunn literally shot
gunned Monster Energy Drink grabbed a
knife and chased John Cena into the
stairwell he's obviously a professional
look how he's dressed Amber leaving us
very curious about what profession
they're referring to well superhero or
supervillain is in the mix this costume
doesn't rule out being cast as Gaston at
Disney world seven years not once have
you mentioned Cinderella I talk about
Cinderella at least once a week Evan
this couple screaming goes on for all of
this sometime because playing domestic
discontent for Laughs is more important
than making us believe the cops wouldn't
have already kicked this door in Captain
despite being at a vantage point from
which she should be able to see
everything the show wants us to believe
that detective song didn't see
Peacemaker jump down before and doesn't
see the officers being shot with darts
right now the Binks fidelmeyer strategic
combat certification must not have
included anything about out keeping the
vehicle running while you're the getaway
driver the thing better not back there
trip announcement for anyone who brings
a kid into my car somehow makes it into
the episode also this thing has several
bullet holes in it and will likely be
trashed since the police are looking for
it so why are you worried about Birch
can't Australian Eagle dude not without
stealing its Soul wait what Peacemaker
knows how to steal souls are we sure
this isn't a backdoor pilot for a
Constantine series
what NBC already made and canceled a
this typing or lack thereof is probably
going to be mostly semicolons that's
possible for this guy with two thumbs it
is that's not how that works but good
Burns response reminds me that the
dialogue of this episode is 80 people
saying stupid but only about 40 people
calling them on their stupid [__] your
kid isn't Christopher Smith Peacemaker
if these two detectives already have
this level of awareness about Peacemaker
how did they not recognize his stupid
shiny head running from the scene of the
crime last night yeah I'm not gonna text
you when I'm taking a shot this was a
bit confusing I took this to me and then
he wasn't going to text him while he was
taking a which is an outright lie
because we all do it but the actual
debate is about whether or not he would
tax to notify economists that he was
planning or in the process of pinching a
loaf that subtle difference really threw
me off and if you're wondering why I'm
going on and on about the subtle
differences in poop speech then welcome
to TV sins
you did not it was very much night when
that happened and we've already seen the
detectives complete a very daytime visit
to peacemaker's father so if you've been
driving that whole time then the only
thing that just happened was myrn
dropping a deuce you sent him fake news
of course not you'd have to be news
first boom that's why they call me the
shade maker it's a line of patio
umbrellas isn't it well I'd rather be
with Harley Quinn than you I'd rather be
with the weasel than you I'd rather be
with [__] bat might than you these
gratuitous name drops are offensive on
their own so it seems like overkilled
act like we all wouldn't prefer hanging
out with those characters even if
Peacemaker was pleasant to be around
fun fact that my predates You by seven
years Peacemaker so he should really be
asking that question after seeing you
and your ridiculous helmet just break
your knife seems like something someone
might want me to remove a sin for so I'm
adding one instead why do all of you
have such weird lessons trying to be
excellent at surname sins when you
forsaken your own in favor of a nom de
geur I don't even like when my balls are
in somebody's mouth okay it gives me the
wrong type of chills and all I can think
about is how long it's been since I've
gotten checked for testicular cancer I'm
sure someone who's willing to put your
balls in their mouth would also be
willing to tell you that one of them has
a weird texture so informal as it may be
that technically might count as being
checked vampire now all the characters
in the room ignore this question adding
into the list of things this episode
refuses to explain because moving the
story along was deemed less important
than showing off how silly quirky and
horny this show can be for me to take
care of them like thinking guns make a
brute sound when they obviously go pew
pew no cheese
just convince them not to fing a
peacemaker not asking Peacemaker if he
Minds being fingered everybody hates you
John Cena is fantastic in this role he
touches on Comedy moronic bravado and
years of unchecked psychological damage
that started with his childhood go ahead
and take one sin off for the man I can't
see the oldest trick in the book I look
in your [__] rock hard you throw my
face reading are you trying to bribe us
no
hoping you're trying to bribe us if you
haven't asked questions like this all
the time and not only when he's trying
to deceive the viewer then it's pretty
easy to see why his marriage is on the
Rocks when I find out someone murdered
an innocent person or sold somebody
heroine or did some graffiti and I
killed that person with my bare hands
their eyeballs popping out of their
skulls you think that gives me pleasure
I'm sure I'll come to appreciate
vigilante in future episodes but it's
hard not to see him as a discount
Deadpool right now so I'll make you a
promise if I do come to like him in the
future I'll take a set off I've been
saving up appliances ever since you were
arrested a ceramic teapot is not an
appliance
writers came up with this whole montage
of these two doing a bunch of foolish
like this and wants us to believe that
they've both survived this friendship
with all their limbs and genitals intact
that Merced is just
too adorable so the show gets us in
along with Humanity for what we've done
to the descendants of wolves you know
that I'm gonna be working some weird
hours
and I was thinking maybe you in the fair
kids well you know no I don't know show
makes it seem like this is a simple
having to choose between work and family
situation but doing clandestine Ops
involving assassinations and beautifully
ornate insects changes things up a bit
and increases likelihood that your
partner would understand your desire to
not put them In Harm's Way so whether or
not the show confirms my suspicions Kia
is a villain three years ago I would
have shot both of you in the face for
that everything about this scene
suggests that you did shoot both of them
in the face albeit the kind of shot
Loosely related to currency but I'd say
it counts no
can't believe they legalized that weed
is still illegal under federal law so if
that's your only requirement I don't see
what's stopping you the no fighting rule
I understand but no horseplay how would
you even get horses into this tiny rec
room I thought we sent capes over to
Arkham Where Bell Reef I know you're
using Arkham for Batman name recognition
but Evergreen is in Washington state why
would you send the prime suspect in a
local murder across the country
the white dragon James got made it clear
that he wanted there to be no sugar
coating in the fact that peacemaker's
father was a racist piece of [__] and
should be hated as such the writing of
the character along with Robert
Patrick's performance definitely gets
across just how serious and diabolical
this character's motivations are in the
same way I don't want to detract from
the seriousness of the subject by making
a joke about falcor's twitch channel so
I'll just send that intolerance and
bigotry are apparently going to be their
own never-ending story can I keep this
one sure episode out is oddly okay with
the police equivalent of a HIPAA
violation
[Music]
why not just take the elevator hey
Harcourt you want to see me rub one out
well you can have his ass nobody's gonna
want to watch that hey man what's up I'm
here for the gangbang you were in the
bathroom I didn't know if you were going
one or two are you not aware that I got
farty and Bloated with a foamy latte why
not spoon
everybody in the world uses spoons
because there's a dull you twit it'll
hurt more my [__] vampire now you're
more of a fun vampire Heidi whities what
do you eat I have no clue what that is
why are we playing charades it's fun
look
look at that thing